there is one thing i want to mention
there's some
very good physiology that can perhaps
support the actual running effort part
these are very new data and we have a
study going on
with david spiegel at stanford looking
at how different patterns of breathing
can affect heart rate variability heart
rate variability is good
there's this interesting mechanism i
think most people might
not realize but that medical students
learn that your breathing and your
heart rate and your brain are in this
really remarkable interplay it goes like
this
when you inhale this isn't breath work
we're not going to do breath work
but when you inhale the diaphragm moves
down
the heart gets a little bigger because
there's a little more space in the
thoracic cavity
and as a consequence blood flows a
little bit more slowly through that
larger volume
there's a category of neurons the
sinoatrial node
that sees that that recognizes that that
slower
rate through that larger volume sends a
signal to the brain stem and the brain
stem sends a signal back to the heart to
speed the heart up
so every time you inhale you're speeding
the heart up when you exhale
the diaphragm moves up the heart gets a
little smaller the volume is smaller
blood flows more quickly through the
heart signal sent up to the brain and
the brain sends a signal back
to slow the heart down this is the basis
of heart rate variability
so at any point if you feel like your
heart is racing and you feel like you're
working too hard
per unit of effort focus on making your
exhales
longer or more intense than your inhales
if ever you feel like you're truly
flagging you do not have the energy to
get up it's like okay it's time to go
and you're exhausted
you want to draw more oxygen into the
system get your heart rate
going faster now some people when they
hear this probably thinking well this is
really obvious but there's so much out
there about breath work and how to
breathe and all this stuff but no one
talks about how to do it in
real time while you're exerting effort
so this is something like almost like
second by second you can adjust things
to just
in real time based on how you're feeling
but based on the heart rate that's right
the experience of the heart rate
that's right so one thing that could
could be very efficient and we're doing
some work with athletes now
these are unpublished data but if you
while you're running
if you want to get into a nice cadence
of heart rate variability
do double inhales
while you're running what this will do
is when you do the double inhale
has the effect of of reopening the
avioli of the lungs
your lungs are filled with tons of
little sacs when you they tend to
collapse as you fatigue
when you and carbon dioxide builds up in
the bloodstream and that's when we start
getting stress
if you've ever been sprinting you start
getting beat and you're going as hard as
you can what what you really need to do
is double inhale and reinflate these
sacks in the lungs and then offload a
lot of carbon dioxide
so when you're at a steady cadence and
you're feeling good double inhale
exhale double inhale exhale is a
terrific
way to breathe while you're in ongoing
effort by the way
any recommendations or differences in
nose or mouth breathing so nasal
breathing there's
a lot of excitement now obviously about
nasal breathing because of james
nestor's book breath
um there was also if people are going to
know about that book that i do feel like
out of respect for my colleagues there
was a book by
sandra khan and paul ehrlich at stanford
both professors at stanford with a
forward by um jared diamond and robert
zapalski so
some heavy hitters in this book and the
book is called jaws
a hidden epidemic and it's all about how
nasal breathing is better for
us especially kids than being mouth
breathers under most conditions
for sake of improving immunity it turns
out there's a microbiome in the nose
like all sorts of good stuff about nasal
breathing preferentially
but when we exercise you can
you can do pure nasal breathing but the
problem is once you get up to kind of
third and fourth and fifth gear effort
you can't nasal breathe and be at
maximum capacity unless you've been
training it for a very long time
so i would say double inhale through the
nose offload through the mouth so double
inhale
exhale while you're in steady effort and
then if you really feel like you need to
gas it and you're pushing
the data show that then just use
whatever's there
right just go into kind of default mode
because
bringing too much concentration to
something is also going to spend
epinephrine
the goal is to get into that i don't
like the word but the flow state
where you're not thinking too much
you're just an exertion
so these are so these are things that
can help in the transitions
um but i don't think there's any secret
breathing technique
you know anyone who's been in the seal
teams will kind of you know they'll tell
you like there's no
breathing technique right there's a
there's
tools that you can look to from time to
time and these double inhale exhales can
be great for setting heart rate
ability in very quickly and getting into
a steady cadence while you're exercising
but if there's a sprint like if suddenly
you guys are sprinting
ditch the ditch the double inhale exhale
and just sprint
you